hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game uh from Naperville
Illinois was played in round seven of
the very strong Robert Byron Memorial
Tournament and uh yeah this game here uh
it's so complicated that I it's hard to
say if we've had a game this complicated
uh since I started the channel I'm not
counting me caltau games obviously those
are those are extremely complicated uh
but uh this will just not not just make
your head spin this will make you just
turn off the whatever you're using to
watch this and say I'm done with this
I'm not I don't want to see this game
anymore it's that complicated uh so it's
a other Escobar Ferrero Colombian Grand
Master versus tyangi Wang of United
States as I understand it from a couple
of Articles they call him Steve uh so uh
let's see this game let's see this
masterpiece everyone is talking about
here we have Ponte e for by Alder uh
Pawn to C6 the Karo Khan defense with d
for D5 with Knight to C3 and now D
captures any for we have Knight captures
Knight to F6 and we have a trade Knight
captures e captures on F6 and now Pawn
to C3 so all very standard the
tartacular variation of the Karo Khan
the chapter D6 and now Bishop to D3 and
here Knight the A6 uh castles is uh the
main move here but Knight A6 also very
much played the Knight will be
re-maneuvered to C7 and then all depends
on how white continues we have Knights
to E2 Knights the C7 and now Bishop to
F4 offering a trade of Bishops and here
there are a couple of moves that were
played in this position but here we have
Pawn to H5 and it is now as of move 9
that we have a completely new game so
here uh other uh captures on D6 we have
Bishop captures Queen captures Knight to
G3 and now H4 as expected we have Queen
the E2 with check King to f8 and now the
Knight comes the E4 so okay the queen is
attacked we have Queen back to d8 and
here other castles Queen side we have
Pawn to G6 and King the B1 a nice
prophylactic move before starting the
attack on the black king on f8 we have
Pawn to A5 as castles are on opposite
sides of the board it makes sense to
attack your opponent's king as soon as
possible and wider does the same G3 he
wants to capture and then open up the G
file we have Pawn to A4 and now Rook H
to G1 and now uh if uh as I've already
mentioned Michael tal if tal was playing
this he would probably just push H3 here
just to stop the opponent's attack even
even though it's it doesn't even have to
be a good move but he would just play it
but here we have Knight to D5 and now
comes Pawn to A3 stopping Black from
playing Pawn to A3 we have King to G7
and now Queen to F3 putting pressure on
that F6 Pawn uh we have pawned the F5
now attacking the Knight and Knight back
to D2 when now we have Pawn to H3
stopping white from opening up the G
file Knight to C4 the Knight now has
access to this beautiful E5 Square
Knight to F6 and now Queen F4 with
Bishop to E6 now and now Pawn to F3 not
allowing this knife to jump anywhere
on these two squares we have Queen to D5
and now if the Knight moves you have to
be careful then the queen can come to A2
and now Rook D to E1 we have pawned the
B5 attacking the Knight and now Knight
the E3 here it would make sense to kick
away the black queen with Rook to E5 but
uh then we we probably wouldn't have
this game tonight the A3 attacks the
queen and now allows Queen to a to with
check King to C1 Queen to A1 check with
Bishop to B1 and now Bishop to A2 and
already this looks uh very lost for
white uh King to C2 Now The Rook is
helping out with the defense of the
bishop here Bishop to B3 check and Y
just repeats King to C1 and now Knights
the D5 attacking the queen on F4 uh and
here uh you have to really decide what
to play one thing you don't want to do
is open up the C file uh for black to
attack what you want to play here is
Queen to E5 check uh it was not played
in this game but point to E5 is the way
to go I'm just going to show it because
it's very nice and now you play Knight
captures on F5 uh that's how you hold
this with white G captures Queen
captures with checking Jade and now
rookie 4 going for Rook to G4 uh but it
doesn't really matter Bishop A2 again
goes after the bishop and now you have
to settle for some like Queen G5
checking if it King C2 Again The Rook
defends the bishop now Bishop to B3
checking to C1 and we would probably see
another Bishop to A2 and whether black
would uh tried something here to push
for the win but most likely it would be
a draw by rep Edition however in the
game we have Knight captures on D5 and
now C captures on D5 which is not very
dangerous as you opened up the uh C file
for the black Rook with Queen to E5 with
check and now King to G8 uh King to H7
was the way to go King to G8 uh uh
allows whites to get back into the game
and the white doesn't miss this
opportunity or or rather he does but not
by a lot in uh you have to play point to
G4 here uh Ponto G4 here in the game
Queen to D6 was played and now comes
Rook to C8 and now you uh you you're in
all sorts of trouble look at this Rook
the E3 not allowing the sacrifice with
Rook to C3 now comes Pawn to B4 uh we
have Queen captures on B4 now comes King
to G7 and Rook to E7 uh we have rooked
the C4 now attacking the queen and queen
to A5 and here you have to play Rook H
the C8 double up on the C file but here
Rook the A8 was played attacking the
queen and sacrificing a full rook and
this is where the fun really starts here
uh what the black was hoping for is root
capture 78 and if you play this it
actually is a forced made in five real
characters in C3 check B captures Queen
captures uh this was merely a deflection
to get the queen away from the A5 square
and now after Bishop to C2 uh Bishop to
C2 this will just be Checkmate however
after this uh Rook to A8 was played
white finds a solution Rook captures an
F7 with check King to H6 not touching
the Rook even though okay if you capture
The Rook it's still fine Queen captures
and D5 will still be a Perpetual King to
H6 and now look at this Pawn to G4 and
now you cannot capture the White Queen
if you capture the White Queen now then
G5 checking H5 Rook to H7 is a beautiful
double Rook Checkmate here so instead
after G4 King the G5 was played we have
G captures and F5 opening up a discovery
King to F or F captures and G6 check
with a discovery King E3 and now Rook
the E7 check King to F2 and now a most
spectacular moment in the game a rook
eat the E1 was played here but this
isn't the way to go the the true path
the victory was Rook Gita E1 and now
okay not the victory it's um It's A Hard
uh to even imagine this but look at this
Rook captures on A5 now Rook 7 to eat
you with check King characters on F3 now
Rook the E3 with check King to F4 G7 now
preparing to get the queen into the game
and now black would have to find Rook
the A8 stopping this Rook to G3 and now
Rook captures on D4 this is the only way
to play it G8 bringing a queen into the
game Rook capture Sun G8 Rook to F1
check King to E5 and now finally C
captures and D4 with check King
characters and D4 and Rook captures on
G8 leaving the black queen stuck here on
A1 and it would almost be a like a like
a beautiful uh you know a piece of art
but black would have this bishop to A2
move which allows black back into the
game it's actually a fourth draw because
there's nothing better than King to C2
defending and then again Bishop B3
checking to C1 and Bishop D2 it's a
theme that repeats throughout the game
but this is basically what we would get
however after King 2f2 Rook eat the E1
was played and now Rook captures an A5
seems to be a free queen look at this
Rook eat the F1 check King to E3 now
comes Rook to E1 check King to F4 Rook
the G4 with check King captures and now
Rook to G3 with check King to F2 and now
you've ran out of checks with Rook e to
E3 and now uh feel free to pause the
video and try to find the only winning
move for black while I give you a couple
of seconds
uh so for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on sporting you
cannot allow Rook e to F3 check and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Bishop to D1 now without this
bishop to a rook to F3 move uh black is
just up a queen it's still sure you
still have to get the queen out of the
corner but you are up a queen so
congratulations to everyone who found
this uh look at the continuation G7 we
have rooked the B5 now going after that
beat you Pawn now comes Pawn to B4
incredible uh just when you need it it's
always there uh and now it doesn't
matter if you capture a fake capture
some B3 Alpha then G8 brings the queen
into the game and if B to check King to
D2 and black has nothing white is just
completely winning here once you capture
Queen F7 check the black king has
nowhere to go you have to start giving
up material with Bishop F3 Queen to F5
uh absolute Massacre so after B4 Rook
the B8 was played now comes King
characters on D1 because here white is
kind of in a tsuked one there there's no
good move that white can make here
without having access to that F3 square
there's nothing for you so here King
captures and D1 now you have access to
F3 but now we have Queen captures on B1
with check King to D2 Queen to B2 with
check King to D1 and now Rook captures
on D4 with check C captures with Queen
captures with check Rook the D3 blocking
and now Queen to A1 with check King to
C2 Queen to A2 with check King to D1 and
now Queen to E2 with check King to C1
and this is the magic moment where black
should have played Rook to C8 with check
but he played Rook the E8 which okay you
can still play it but the reason why
Rook to C8 check wasn't played and it
seems like such an obvious move is
because of the following Rook the C3 now
you can't capture if capture is just a
draw remember white still has this past
pawn queen to E1 check would have to be
played King to C2 and only now Rook uh
sorry Rook captures on C3 with check
Rook characters and queen to G one
stopping the promotion and now you are
just completely winning the problem is
you have to see what happens after Rook
the G3 now you play Queen captures on H2
and now after G8 Queen you just trade
Queen characters and G3 and after Queen
captures on D5 it seems okay you're only
up uh it's equal material uh Queen and
pawn end game but there's H2 the black
H2 Pawn is now just much too strong and
now it's completely winning for black
for example some Queen to D to check
action King G1 and after you escape a
few checks um uh after King to F2 there
are no more checks Queen to D2 check
will be met with Queen the E2 you have
to trade and then H1 Queen is just
winning so Rook the C8 although uh kind
of uh seemingly obvious you do have to
calculate a lot but so instead Rook the
E8 was played of course black uh feels
that whatever black plays is just
winning but now comes Rook the C3 and
now the problem is there's only one
winning move for black and if you guys
spot this one then you are probably the
greatest player to ever watch chess
videos on YouTube so feel free to pause
the video and win the game for black
while I give you a couple of seconds you
know for Steve do it for Steve
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
seemingly unspotable move and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Queen to E5 this is the the
important move Queen to E5 it wasn't
played in the game but if if it was uh
there's uh not much you can do you
cannot promote because then just throw
captures and after you captures the rook
and C3 hangs with check and if you don't
do that look at this Rook the C2 uh with
check you're gonna play King the F1 get
out of checks now King to B1 and now you
have to find Queen captors on G3 this is
the move you have to find when you
played Queen to E5 and now it's fairly
simple H captors and G3 just King to G1
H2 is coming Rook to C1 check now the
problem King to G2 Rook to C2 check
you're gonna play King to F3 not capture
if you capture it's a draw uh remarkable
as that is King to F3 Rook to H2 now you
defend your pawn and now uh slowly but
surely the pawns will start to fall King
C2 Rook G8 then the G7 plus G3 false and
there's nothing for white here so that
was the only path to Victory from this
positions however uh to win the F1 check
was played and now King the B2 we have
rooked the E2 with check and now Rook
the C2 Rook captures King captures Queen
to eat you with check King to C1 we have
Queen to E1 checking to C2 and now Queen
to e for with check King to C1 Queen to
H1 with check King to B2 and now Queen
captures on H2 but now comes uh Rook to
G5 the only move that saves the game for
white as you don't allow Queen to E5
check now comes King to E3 opening up a
discovery just King the A1 and again
there's no defense against the G8 queen
or rather there is and that the defense
is a Perpetual uh checking sequence
Queen to H1 check uh and uh this is like
there were so many great moments in the
game but this could be the greatest King
the A2 was played King the B2 is the
only move that draws King the 80 was
played and this is now again completely
winning for black but still you it's
very hard to see why why King the A2 is
lost for white and King to B2 is a draw
for white the reason is next
um in the game uh Queen to H2 check was
played and they just uh you know agreed
to a drawback repetition but the move
that actually wins is Queen to E4 I move
that uh seemingly makes no sense but now
when you see what happens if G8 Queen is
played Ponte H2 and you actually allow
rook and the queen to to be on the board
but there's just no way for white to
survive this you're gonna play Rook the
G3 check it's the only useful check you
have uh King F2 and that's it you have
no more checks you can't do anything H1
a queen is coming you can play Rook to
H3 you can't move the queen because King
just captures Rook so you can play
something like Rook to H3 but now look
at this queen T2 with check whatever you
play King the B1 Queen to F1 with
checking to C2 just Queen characters
next move you promote not next movie
after you you know Escape all the checks
you will promote the H Pawn and win the
game so remarkable that uh this was
possible uh but it wouldn't be possible
if the King was on B2 and here they just
repeated Queen Tage to check into A1 and
it was in this position on move 69 that
the players agreed to a draw as now
there really is nothing more to be done
here uh so yeah I hope you guys enjoyed
that and I don't know like I said in the
beginning of the video you guys were
probably so disgusted with this game uh
most of you probably didn't even finish
uh until the end but you know for those
of you who did uh truly congratulations
and especially if you found both pause
the video moments I mean this is
absolutely incredible we've had some
complicated games but this is just you
know bends and breaks the mind
uh so yeah I really hope you hope you
enjoyed it once again thanks David Lada
for sending me such a such a such a gym
of a game to share with everyone I would
like to thank Jordan Smith
and Alejandro Maldonado ravishing
reptiles YouTube for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing uh to check up on your
wonderful suggestions such as this one
and whatever else happens in the Chess
World so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day